hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
recently I jumped back into infamous
second son and noticed the sheer volume
of easter-egg secrets and cultural
references that are scattered around the
open world if you've picked up second
cent on PS Plus then here's 40 things I
think you should witness with your own
eyes on your way to picking up the
platinum trophy of course as we are all
gamers here let's start off with the
video game references in infamous second
son early on in the game went Delson
wakes in the longhouse take a minute or
two to look around the converted
hospital just before you meet Betty
you'll find a doll which looks very
similar to another PlayStation exclusive
title knack there's also numerous nods
to the Sly Cooper series with many books
around the longhouse called the thieves
racoon collection if you don't know the
Sly Cooper franchise it was created by
sucker punch on the ps2 ps3 and the Vita
as well basically sly is a raccoon from
a long line of master thieves so this
collection of books are a fitting
acknowledgement to the devs past also in
the longhouse are many children's
pictures one of which looks very much
like a raccoon who's up to no good the
Sly Cooper references coming thick and
fast throughout the game listen closely
to delson's mobile phone theme could you
place the reference it's the theme tune
from Sly Cooper thieves in time
over in Seattle central in the play zone
are many Sly Cooper s images three
raccoons holding items synonymous with
the series slice Cain hat and swag bag
close by our graffiti versions of slide
Bentley and Murray the hippo if you pay
attention to the LED signs in the
Rainier district you'll also notice that
Sly Cooper has been arrested for
burglary little thieving sheets and
looks lies logo is on the billboards
it's on graffiti it's on neon signs it's
everywhere in the game second CERN also
pays homage to the previous games in the
infamous series throughout the game
Kohl's Electronics is probably the most
noticeable as Cole MacGrath was the hero
of villain depending on how you played
the first infamous titles and of course
his skill set included electricity more
infamous references come in the shape of
posters for upcoming movies and musicals
Empire City was the place infamous
started and Gigante was the final boss
by clearing the district showdown
missions in each area of Seattle a new
jacket is unlocked by completing the
downtown area you'll unlock Zeke's lucky
7 jacket a nod to Cole's best mate in
infamous 1 & 2 and his favorite t-shirt
design back in the long house one of the
children's drawings depicts Cole
defeating the Reaper gang - there are so
many more references to both fly Cooper
and the infamous franchise but we'll
come back to those the fictitious video
game used in second son is heavens
Hellfire and the swords used in this
game resemble the master sword in the
Legend of Zelda series the blue grip the
winged handles are almost identical but
of course they aren't for copyright
reasons the sword is in various places
including Eugene's apartment I mean
Blair also in here is a video game disc
named Call of DUP which looks
suspiciously like a reference to the
Call of Duty franchise
Eugene's treasure trove continues with
many arcade cabinets - check out the
artwork on the side of this machine
resembles the Ikari warriors and their
growing love of bandanas moustaches and
instruments of death there's also one
video game I can't figure out so help
would be appreciated under this cloth
are three arcade machines from right to
left its second son Sly Cooper but I
can't make out the third
I looked at sucker-punches back catalog
and the only other franchise they've
worked on is rocket robot on wheels
that's probably a long shot so maybe
it's a new game they're currently
working on fingers crossed
time will tell a non-specified reference
comes in the shape of the graffiti tag
Delson creates during the games i know
political graffiti is nothing new but
the style of pop culture and political
satire resemble the work of Banksy a
British political artist merging dark
humor and social commentary there are
also a few TV and film references in
second son the one I enjoyed was the
burger shop burger Royale with cheese in
many locations this one is in the
belltower district this is a nod to the
pup fiction film and the ramblings of
two hitmen you know what they call a TV
reference and upon all in one next you
may have noticed the crane during your
missions with Eugene well the
organization running these gigantic
cranes unknown as Fraser if you're as
old as I am you probably made the
connection already Fraser was an
American sitcom in the 90s set in
Seattle the same place second son is set
and Frazier's last name crane so this is
afros ukraine brilliant
speaking of seattle infamous second son
does a great job of referencing the
landmarks you'd expect you know like the
big-ass Space Needle but there are
references to the city which don't stand
out to everyone I won't cover everything
but here's my favorites a local landmark
how the gum wall is replicated in second
son so it's not a mind-blowing
architectural accomplishment it's simply
an alley covered in used chewing gum
gross but brilliant at the same time
sadly the real gum wall in Seattle was
removed in 2015 but the local populace
went straight back to work and began to
build up the wall yet again if you want
to find this monument in the game make
your way over to the Market District and
keep chewing Seattle other pieces of
Seattle recreated are the squatch Java
billboards which are based on Seattle's
Bigfoot Java the local football team are
here to reference with the Seahawk
posters I'm sure you were taken back
when you saw
the tow truck over in the pioneer
district gotta love those buttons this
is a real vehicle in Seattle
Lincoln's tow truck one day I will
breakdown in Seattle and be told by that
beast
have you heard of Phoenix Jones well he
may look like he enjoys S&M but in fact
he's a real-life superhero operating in
and around Seattle
you really have to Google this gent he's
an absolute legend like you oh the
police in Seattle like us now they
didn't like us when we started but they
liked us now in infamous second son
Phoenix posters can be spotted
everywhere paying homage to the
real-life crime fighter let's keep going
the pure camp soda machines throughout
the city
are in reference to John's soda a brand
created you've guessed it in Seattle
another pun comes in the shape of a faux
noodles restaurant which uses the word
pho to make an hilarious infamous pun
lovely another company given a place in
second son is the elephant carwash
company recreated almost perfectly as to
is the crocodile a music venue there's
even a jacket to unlock feature in the
croc after you complete the Paramount
district on your map even the end
credits are and not to Seattle's impact
on the world with a cover of Nirvana's
heart-shaped box
[Music]
[Applause]
and just in case you didn't know they
were formed in Seattle a few more brands
are here to be named checked with a few
letters missing of course go over to the
Rainier district and look at the screens
advertising the heavens hell-blade video
game the review quotes are from bro Taku
a parody of Kotaku and Game Informer are
here - under the name game advisor sort
of but clever Lamballe me and Filch are
a front for fashion house Abercrombie &
Fitch and I'm sure you've noticed the
similarities with the dozens of coffee
shops around the city which are based on
Starbucks arguably there's a few Xbox
references in infamous second son the
first is a jacket unlocked after
completing the uptown district it's a
simple skull and crossbone design but
it's referenced as X bone that must be a
coincidence right there can't be
anything to do with the Xbox one I'm not
sure the second potential Xbox Easter
Egg is on the Boxton building of an air
Dini Park again I'm uncertain if this
has any reference to Xbox but the color
scheme the shapes used and even that
weird trail thing off the Xbox logo is
here I'm not sure if this is a legit
Easter Egg what do you think oK we've
almost made it to the end let's power
through over to the park where we saw
the Sly Cooper images is a castle called
Draycott this was created by a dev
putting his own name in the game
he's called Alex Draycott by the way the
developing studio Sucker Punch has a few
subtle name drops in seconds on to a few
drawings in the long house have their
logo and at the bottom of the giant
screens in the rainy a district also
bear their logo oh I almost forgot the
final yellow billboards which represent
the end of the district have a phone
number attached 184 for help DUP well if
you decide to call that number you will
receive a pre-recorded message from the
leader of the DUP Augustine please stay
on the line for an important message
from our director Brooke Augustine
bioterrorist what do you think when you
hear that word Cole MacGrath
the Beast fear oppression I'm here to
tell you that Cole and all the other bio
terrorists were once ordinary people
just like you they didn't know and
lurking within them with a sickness a
gene that would transform them into
something violent and terrible a gene
that could be inside you bioterrorism
can be stopped but it has to start with
you do your part for a brighter brought
to you by the department of unified
protection here to help I said earlier
that they were more Sly Cooper an
infamous Easter eggs well here they are
during the first mission to get to
Seattle a removal truck is in the tunnel
referencing both Cole MacGrath
and Sly Cooper surnames the slogan is we
take your stuff and put it somewhere
else
perfectly summing up the duo this could
also be a reference to the Merc Cooper
clan again from the sly series in
paramount there are some sort of
solicitors once again teaming up Cooper
and McGrath a few final thinks there's a
hidden poster of infamous on the wall
inside many buildings all under panda
king petrol station or gas station if
you prefer is a name check to the
character in the Sly Cooper series today
go what have I missed
forty Easter eggs references and just
cool little pieces of info there are so
many mod knobs and references to Seattle
but I don't know the city well enough to
notice them so if you do please help us
out let us find more Easter eggs
together I imagine from PlayStation
grenade it's been a pleasure I'll see
you next time
you